And now everybody it's not your cabin cutters and as I promised I was going to get together some
But my heartfelt thoughts in a series called the Seven Day Soul Clens. No, I don't
Even remember why I called it the Seven Day Soul Clens. So you know, honestly, I almost like to just cross that out. But I don't know what else to call
I don't know what else to call it because this is gonna be a series of messages that is coming from my heart
regardless of where you're at with your
thought process of
Your relationship with God. We're regardless of where you're at with what religion you are what church you go to. I don't care
But I would you know just pray that you hear this out and
That God takes whatever I have here to say
That he somehow miraculously
He races the wrong and
And leaves the truth
To be gleaned in your heart that it could grow
Something beautiful. That's my prayer. Let's begin with prayer as we start this
Heavenly Father, it's come for you trusting you in your ways. You are sovereign in all things
We give you thanks in glory and praise for you are good
And you have said that not a sparrow falls to the ground
Without you knowing it you care for us so much more than you care for
For a sparrow and you know that
What we need to hear you know
What we need to be exhorted what we need to be disciplined through
In Lord, I pray that you just
Allow that in our life so that we may
Bring you more glory that we may be molded and shaped to the image of your son
That we may hug her and thirst for your righteousness in all things
We pray these things in Jesus name
So this is going to be an introduction to this
Seven-day Soul Clubs if you want to call it that I don't know how many days it's gonna be and I don't know how many messages just gonna be
So stick with me with this some title of this is from
Wonderful bed who lived back in the 1940s and was
Was
butchered by the Nazi regime
The guy named Dietrich Budhofer who stood up for Christ in the middle of Nazi Germany and would not bow to
What he was told to do and he has a famous quote that says when Christ calls
The man he bids him come to die and that's very
Scriptural
And I know that you know we are cancer clinic in a chronic Lyme clinic and we have people that are suffering greatly
But most of our patients that come to us are coming to us often the last
Ditch effort to stay alive
And I don't want to belittle those facts
But I want to share something with you that I haven't shared with very many of my patients up to this point
This may be the first time you're hearing it
It may not but I too have a diagnosis of cancer
I to have done an IVG tested
I have an IVG score that's worse than the vast majority of my patients
I've been having symptoms for some time now and I suspected
uh
That to be true
That's why I did an IVG test
My symptoms have been getting worse. I sometimes
Think that my conditions getting better that I feel better
But most often I feel like my conditions getting worse that I feel worse
So I'm in the same position as you are
But I don't share that because I want your pity. Matter of fact, I
Alive your pity
Do I want your prayers? I covet your prayers, but not for my
Healing yes, I want to be healed pray for my healing. I take that back
I'd rather have your prayers for my sanctification
For my holiness for my growing in a deeper relationship with Jesus Christ
Through this
And that God will take this situation that I'm in and turn it to his glory
In his God and I think that is really should be the prayer of be all the time
But it's not because I'm a selfish human being and I want what I want and I don't want to have cancer
I don't want to die. I'm too young to die. I got too many goals and dreams and plans in my life
Good to say I got how can you take this away for me look at all I've done for you
I don't do a whole lot of things for fun for myself. I
Dedicated myself to a practice of trying to help your people
And try to see people come
To your truth and try to help people overcome this disease that now I have for Pete's sake. This isn't fair
For all that little banter is a display of my own self-centeredness. Isn't it good to say I am a narcissistic person in my flesh
Because all I want is what I want
Well, isn't it godly?
Dr. Clouders to want to be healed. How can you say that that's not godly?
That's not necessarily flesh late. Well, sure we want to be healed the people that came to Jesus when he walked on this earth
Jesus asked what do you want? I want to see I blind. I want to see I want to be healed
I want my daughter to to live she's she's dying my son is is
Epileptic and he's seizes and he's going crazy and people say he's full of the devil. I need him to be healed Jesus
It's only normal to want to be whole
It's only normal that we don't want to die
We were born
It created to live forever
In a perfect relationship with our Heavenly Father and sin entered the world and broke that
It's only normal to let that back
But in Jesus Christ we already have that back
See, I believe from the depth of my heart that the kids are kid to kill me
It can't go to sex. I wrote a book about this I think
It can't kill me if I'm already dead
Because I have died to this life
And sometimes I'll be the first to admit that it raises back up with me and and I feel sorry for myself
And I cry and I whine and I pout and I don't want to have this and what am I supposed to do Lord to get better
This isn't even a good example to my patients good to say I'm a cancer doctor and I got cancer
Well, how good is my therapy for crying out loud
Who's gonna believe my testimony
And yet God sees fit
It is it is lovingness
He loves me enough
To allow this in my life
To bring him glory
Although so often in my flesh I would have fallen
But he brings me back
And it gives me the grace to repent
So that he could get the glory through this the other day I was prayed and told my wife this this weekend that
I said you know
I mean just asking the Lord just cried out in my quiet time with him that
That oh Lord you know
What what do you want for me with this
And it was very few times that I feel like I hear the Lord speak to me so don't get too crazy that I'm totally whacked out
But this is what if them that I just really feel in the depth of my heart and the quietest of my soul
Then he said
I used you for years to help cancer patients and I'm continuing to do that
But now I want cancer in you to be used to bring me glory
So you're gonna see a little change in me. I hope I hope by the grace of God
Then I could bring him glory through this
And that many can come to him through this truth
So this is going to be a seven day soul cleanse. I don't know. Maybe it's going to be a seven hundred day soul cleanse
But I'm going to be giving you the messages from my heart and what God's teaching me how to overcome this
These messages are going to be more more spiritual
love hardly any
Physical in the sense that um take curcumin or
Boswellia for inflammation you know another other messages for that this piece is for the cleansing of our soul
This is for a renewed of our spirit
This is to bring us to the point where
Yes, we are to do we're to ask for wisdom and walk in wisdom in this world
I prayed that prayer which is about every one of you and share that truth with
Every patient that I've had that that's what our calling is here on earth. We ask for wisdom
We pray for wisdom. We walk in that wisdom as best we know how and trust God to work in that
Whether that be I'm going to do chemo or I'm not gonna do chemo or I make this decision and I do this supplement
I do this diet and we follow this regimen
Yes, because we do
selfishly
What to live
To succeed to have success on this earth
But we we we we buffer that with
Please eat our heavenly Father
First of all and we have to be so careful
I have to be so careful
That I don't make healing this cancer and idle in my life
Oh, it's so tempting isn't it
Because that's a good thing. I'm not talking about you know boats or cars or or success or houses boy
That's easy to call that an idle and I would never fall into idolatry like that and forsake
By heavenly Father for that
How could you say healing cancer is a bad thing? How could you say that could be an idle anything that we
put our
Time into our faith into our soul into our dedication into greater than we put into our relationship with our heavenly Father
And bringing him glory
I challenge you is an idle in your life
That idolatry is an abomination before God
So I'm the first one I'll get out my decent repent
I need a savior more than I need
A supplement
I need a savior more than I need a new therapy
Don't get me wrong. There's other wrong supplements and medicine therapies and healings and
The first and fourth
First and foremost
We need a relationship with our heavenly Father and be nurturing that on a daily basis and a moment to moment basis and praise God
I am saying this for me praise God for my cancer
Told my staff today. Hey, I could just I could have just dropped dead of heart attack
I could have got run over by a boss. I could have just you know got
In a plane crash I could have got it a boating accident
Never would be able to contemplate the things that I'm contemplating now
But praise God for a diagnosis that is
Terminal that could bring you to a point of realizing that you are always terminal for the beginning
Nobody's getting it out of this
planted
alive
And we're not bringing anything with us. We all know that but we don't want to contemplate that
Terminality and we want to live for today
Praise God
for my cancer
Thank you heavenly Father for this diagnosis to bring me back to the love of my life
that
gives me eternity
So with that yes
When Christ calls a man he bids him to come and die
die to our flesh
die to our aspirations die to our goals
die to our plans die to our future die to
our
harmonies that and and idols that we've created and set up before him
in order to have joy exceeding
Love a bounding
peace that's unspeakable
and
Freedom from a fear freedom from
Self-centeredness freedom from my own selfish darsicism
Praise God for that and I need to hold on to him for that for victory over myself
on a daily basis
So with that is our introduction
sorry
And this sermon series this
Serbant series sorry about that. Well, that's probably what it's going to be
Is going to be a Matthew chapter five
First three particularly
This is God gave me this life verse years and years ago. That's why my
Email is Dr. Kevin 53
That was my email when I first got my email long before I was in my fifties and people would say oh are you 53?
No, that's my really my life verse Matthew five three says blessed
Blessed are the poor and spirit for theirs is the kingdom of heaven and we're going to unpack that piece
Um over the next um several
Uh
Times that we get together here
Uh, and we're going to break that down into the Greek and we're going to break that apart to understand that
But in first and order to do that we have to we have to kind of give a foundation
Aware that's coming from and I know that
My patients that are hearing this many of you are believers and
None of this is new to you and you can relate to everything that I'm saying and and what I say things like I don't want my
Helied to become an idol in my life. You're you're there with me and you're saying amen. I don't want that either
I just want to do what God wants me to do
But I know he wants me to fight this and he wants me to
To to have victory over this or work towards that victory. Oh, I don't know why maybe it's to heal me
Maybe it's not a piece. I'm at complete peace with dying
I want to go to heaven and be with my Savior and worship him always and bring him glory and live in his glory and see him
It is a full glory on the throne and experience that and learn more about him on a daily basis and spend eternity
Finding more deep beauty in our heavenly Father. That's going to blow my mind
But I also feel like I have a purpose here on earth and I can say just like Paul said to live
It's Christ meeting if I live here on earth
I want to serve him and it's going to bring him glory and I'm going to see my grandchildren come to a deeper knowledge of him
And I'm going to be able to see people that I come in contact with come to Christ because of my testimony
But for goodness thanks to die is gained to die is even better
So I'm not trying to just stay away from death. I'm trying to serve him more and I don't want to just give up to death
What I feel like God has so much more for me
And there's others listening to this that have a defaithous idea what I just said
And they're just come what in the world are you talking about I thought I came to a clinic where you had all these answers for
Cancer patients and now you're preaching to me a gospel that good to say
I heard this in church. I can't stand listening to this stuff. I don't want to hear this
Maybe you tuned me out already, but please hear me through this
Let God speak to you in this
This cancer that you have this whatever disease you have whatever troubles you have
What other problems you have it going through divorce you going to trouble times your finances or or destitute whatever struggles
You have don't waste your struggles
Unself centered thought don't waste your struggles thinking that it's about this earth and I would be so
All I need is this struggle to go away and I'll be okay
God has allowed this in your life
It is sovereignty
To mold you and shape you to the image of the Sun that I really believe that if you're listening to this if you came to our clinic
There's a little piece of you even if you're not a believer there's a piece of you that hunkers
For his righteousness
And you can't hunger for the righteousness of God
Unless God himself put it there in your heart
The nurture of that water that will seed
Of that hunger for his righteousness
And it's only when we water that and we start to starve the idols
What do we feed the hunger and thirst for the word of God in his glory and we start to starve our fleshly desires
Boy kids are gonna do that for you can't it
Because
They're taken away from you sometimes
Financial collapse can certainly destroy your towers of glory that you've built in your boats and your houses and stuff when you lose those things
And when your health starts to crumble
And you don't know where to turn and the doctors have given you this bad prognosis and and you don't know what to do
It's easier to turn
To God
Praise God for that
That's why I titled my books not fighting cancer and start treating the cause years and years and years ago if you read the final chapter of that book
I haven't read it for years, but
It's it's it's it is it about curing cancer praise God if we can live for years, you know, when we were given two weeks to live praise God
For that
But it's more about
learning to love him and to bring him glory even in the midst of our struggles and our problems and our cancer and our
financial loss and our divorces and our
pain and our agony and
Why is this bad thing happening to me? I don't care. I'm trusting God through it no matter what
That's our lesson in this
So without further ado
This is our introduction
It's going to be our lesson through this is going to be through Matthew five three
And we're going to start
Matthew chapter one
But that is going to be for day one
So with that will leave you and um, I will see you very soon
Thanks